did your parents say you could have a
party no
hello I'm Claudia O'Doherty and these
are some of my favorite videos on
YouTube that I watched I watch them
every day before I leave the house
otherwise I can't go outside the first
one is a video called I'm Zack I was
born 13 years ago Washington DC I think
it was made for this boy Zacks Bar
Mitzvah it's so sweet because of Zack
singing a song about himself and about
what he loves and he loves Oprah and
Emeril Lagasse I'm Zack Stan's back his
dad is certainly very involved in the
concepts of the video it's heavily
influenced by Robert Palmer
so it's lots of little children dressed
as Robert Palmer girls which obviously I
don't think back who's 12 would have any
knowledge of it's full of so much stuff
and I think it's so funny and so sweet
don't you say you to be Zachary they're
all wearing fedoras which is terrible
but I think when you're 12 you can get
away with it
so the next video is called passive
nightmares it's a very confronting video
made by some Irish youth
here's the noise nothing here I guess I
like videos by young people who don't
really understand what they're doing
it's a very scary video warning of the
dangers of passive smoking you're
disgusting and it's very confusing all
of acting is very bad but it's still a
very powerful message
they've all got horror movie costumes on
lots of times people get uncomfortable
in their costumes and take them off
before the end of the same evening my
favorite scene is like a girl with a
Chucky mask on on a tricycle talks to
the killer from scream and they both
take their masks off before the end of
the scene unless that was on purpose and
I didn't understand the creative meaning
behind it but it's a very good movie
called passive nightmares
[Music]
the next video I have is quite don't hug
me I'm scared and it's the time video
these people they're from the UK and
they make incredible videos they're so
funny come on guys stop mucking around
you only have five minutes until our
shows on time
it's like puppets and art and it's all
sort of psychedelic and it's a little
bit like pee-wee's Playhouse but super
original time is a tool you can put on
the wall or wear it on your wrist and
it's just so funny and this is just a
very genuine one I love it watch all of
their videos time by don't hug me I'm
scared my daddies I can't come Sudan the
next one is another very serious video
it's called the power of the witch and
it's a documentary that the BBC made in
1971 it's very boring it's about an hour
long anything
doreen Valiente is a week and she
believes that witch crowd should never
be approached lightly it's just a
documentary about what witches are up to
in the UK in 1971 on one estimate there
are 30,000 people practicing in
witchcraft in this country alone a more
conservative figure would be 8,000 it's
sort of like a Christopher Guest movie
because like no one really knows how to
be on television people are like
confused they don't know where to look
Ayana of the rounded moon the queen of
all enchantments here but they're also
very matter-of-factly talking about
being witches and I love it the word
which originally means wise one my final
video is party boy Corey Worthington
appearing on the Australian tabloid news
show a Current Affair well it's the
real-life risky business a teenager
holds an alcohol-fueled party party boy
Corey Worthington is an Australian icon
he had a party work that he put on
Facebook while his parents were away and
he think like 2,000 people came and they
destroyed the house
what were you thinking I wasn't really
did your parents say you could have a
party no this interview is incredible
because it takes place before his
parents have actually gotten in touch
with him I haven't really talked to him
because every time they call I don't
answer because yeah approach I'd kill me
he's like not remotely intimidated by
being on television his shirt is open
you can see both of his nipples and he
gives the best answers to every single
question why don't you take your glasses
off so we can see you and then apologize
to your neighbors for frightening nah
I'll leave these on I like them this
woman who I'm sure like is finding him
very funny as well but she has to act
appalled take a few glasses and
apologize to us I'll say sorry but I'm
not taking all my glasses
why not cuz they're famous because your
glasses are famous yeah and he's
remained sort of a celebrity in
Australia and they think everything is
the media checks in on what he's doing
and I think he's married and very happy
now well we've got to go but I suggest
you go away and take a good long hard
look at yourself I have everyone has
they love it thank you so much for
watching I hope you really loved my
favorite videos goodbye Team Coco that's
what has been going on in this country
since the last of the witchcraft laws
was repealed in 1951